MIKKO, SCORE!
RANTANEN.
PUCK COMES ACROSS.
A CHIP UP AND OVER.>> WITH THATN
GO.
>> JOHANSEN A BIG GUY.
THE
MEGNA.
ATTACKER COMING ON.
HAND OUT.
OF COURSE,ON.
SHOT BLOCKED.
PICKED UPKAR.
THEY'RE PAIRING GIRARD AND BOWEN
BYRAM TOGETHER. TIMER, HEE PUTT.
THE PASASIVELY EXPLODE
SFIP HIS
A SCORE. COULD
DEF
ON FOUR POWER PLAY GOALS.
MAYBE YOU GET AN OPPORTUNITY ONE
YOU -- ALL YOU'REATION
BURAKOVSKY, GAVE IT UP.
HERE COO GO AS KADRI GETS
INVOLVED WITH COUSINS
PENALTY.
FIVE FOR -- THEY LOOKED AT ELITE
AND IF YOU GET A CERTAIN TO BE .
MAN, ONE HAND, PUSHES
ITITN THE SLOT.
SAVED BY JOHANSSON.
OTTAWA
IN THATITH HIS
SECOND GOAL
TEAMMATES THAN TYSON JOST AND
FINALLY